hey guys Ryan Wright is sitting in the
middle today and Jerry is it your screen
right right right right screen right
yeah and I'm a screen left Brandis my
name that's right
so we're gonna check out the true V clip
actually called alive for Jurassic world
starring Chris Pratt and Ron Howard's
daughter she just went and made a new
dinosaur yeah it's kind of what we do
here
the exhibit opens to the public in three
weeks mr. masrani wanted me to consult
with you you want to consult here or in
my bungalow Oh we'd like you to evaluate
the paddock for vulnerabilities why me I
guess mr. masrani thinks since you're
able to control the raptors see it's all
about control with you I don't control
the Raptors it's a relationship it's
based on mutual respect that's why you
and I never had a second baby excuse me
I never wanted as Nick and brings out an
itinerary for a night out I'm an
organized person what kind of a diet
doesn't allow to Keela all of them
actually and what kind of a man shows up
to a date in boardshorts the social
america it's not okay okay
can we just focus on the asset please
the asset look I get it you're in charge
out here you gotta make a lot of tough
decisions it's probably easier to
pretend these animals are just numbers
on a spreadsheet but they're not you're
alive I'm fully aware they're alive you
might have made them at testing but they
don't know that they're thinking I gotta
eat I have a hunt
I got you can relate to at least one of
those things huh I like him I like him a
lot
all that character the bone I want to be
just like him
your character development I'm kind of
not sure what to take from that no
exactly these two people know what one
side of me goes I know exactly who these
two people are I am on board to watch
them go through danger yes but the other
side is like that seemed a little cheesy
yeah pretty corny at times and they kind
of seem like character archetype like
they seemed oh yeah this was the CCB
Hollywood theatre spot up here's their
relationship
here's her personality type and here's
his personality type and they're gonna
get together in the end yeah we used we
went on one date again that romantic
chemistry just happy throw that in there
yeah a lot of like weird exposition her
short hair makes her look like she's 45
though maybe she's supposed to be she's
pretty hot for 45 min 45 days preclude
hotness I like Bryce Dallas Howard she's
pretty cute and she's a good actress
supposedly although she was like the
worst rated movie of all time like lady
in the water and Terminator Salvation
she's great at picking movies so with
Chris Pratt though he is always
entertained watch no matter what you're
watching him in he I thought he stole
the show and um this scene yeah
five-year engagement was actually the
first thing I saw of him he just comes
such a long way since then but five-year
engagement he wasn't even promoted on
the trailers but I thought he was like
the best thing from that film I always
think he's great to watch a Leatherman
guardians I loved him in Parks and Rec
and he seems like he's having fun with
some cliched Hollywood lines right now I
guess so yeah I mean it's like if this
scene was all they released it wouldn't
make me more excited about this movie
like I'm excited about Jurassic Park
because I know what it is and I've seen
the other like trailers this is probably
why they haven't been really doc seem
that's probably why they haven't been
promoting character too much and that's
not exactly what you go to a Jurassic
Park movie for like it's you know but
part one had great character so yeah
that's one of those movies that has
distinct characters and it has enough
character because everything is sort of
in real time my favorite moment from the
first Jurassic Park is when Jeff
Goldblum
the guy over like I would like yeah
because I returned Albert oh yeah Carl
Sanders right and then they're having
the debate at the table of why this is
wrong and why this is okay they're going
back and forth and it's seems like such
a realistic conversation based off the
specific philosophies of these
characters that's the thing is I wish
modern movies like this would do that a
bit more you know you didn't have like
the most fleshed out characters but you
would know who characters were just
based on what they would say in
situations when the philosophies and I
feel like nowadays we get a lot of this
scene where it's like okay we're gonna
take a break to have our characters
explicitly discuss their past or it's
like you know we don't necessarily need
to do that is so true like currently I
think movies have a lot of exposition as
opposed to just allowing them to be the
character like who there whoever they
are yes like people like in real life
you don't stop all the time to be like
our relationship history yeah sometimes
you can develop your characters just by
letting us hear how they feel about
things or think milazzo fees are instead
of being like here's our past every time
I see one of these clips of Jurassic
world I'm always like why the [ __ ] did
they make a hybrid dinosaur and then her
first line is isn't that what we do and
I was like wait what is that you guys
brought bringing back dinosaurs to life
like cloning them is one thing but
making a hybrid is a whole other
situation idiot that's why the park
isn't in trouble because of you [ __ ]
forty five-year-old Bryce Dallas Howard
oh [ __ ]
anyway guys if you're new the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
co-creator of the real rejects has a
playlist called reasons Jerry
check that [ __ ] out Brandi price channel
check it out too
lot of fun stuff film related over there
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter we talk about our
personal life problems as much as
possible yeah I tend to go on rants
about celebrities and then about issues
with my girlfriend and it's it's really
they're really bad really bad stuff that
happens
it's really dope yeah it's really dark
they'll follow me you know if you're
ever feeling depress and you want to get
more depressed obviously you won't feel
better about your brother yeah this is
the real rejects all right guys come on
screenshot time